[Music]  sorry baby  [Music]  move over Alanis Morissette this might  be the ultimate diss track Colombian pop  star Shakira has racked up over 82  million views within two days on her  latest music video becoming the most  watched new Latin song on YouTube within  a 24-hour period the track takes aim at  the singer's ex 35 year old former  footballer Gerard PK over his alleged  relationship with a younger woman  singing You traded a Rolex for a Casio  the song also implies that PK left her  when Spanish authorities accused the  singer of failing to pay 14.5 million  euros in taxes between 2012 and 2014 a  trial date has not been set but the 45  year old could face prison time in a  hefty line of 23 million euros if  convicted PK has not issued a formal  response to the diss track probably  won't respond with another song probably  not I would think not  wow I got to say Michelle has nothing  yeah that's bad I got to say all right